this is footage of a human egg being
born the egg puffs up like a balloon
from a bed of stem cells and Wiggles its
way into existence it's been an uphill
battle to prove this as possible the
prevailing dogma in our field for the
better part of the last 50 or 60 years
was that young girls are given a bank
account of eggs at birth that's not
renewable and as they mature and become
a woman and they use those eggs up the
ovaries will fail and they enter
menopause in 2004 Harvard researcher
Jonathan Tilley published a
controversial paper in Nature it showed
stem cells and the ovaries of adult mice
could give rise to viable eggs the
backlash to the paper was fierce post
2004 after the nature paper was released
was probably the worst in terms of the
skepticism the controversy the debate I
think in one or two calendar years there
were probably thirty scathing
commentaries published on this work by
various people claiming it to be false
made up simply not believable we were
reminded that humans are not big mice
only if you're in Disneyland because it
was a mouse study and obviously we had
to work very hard to try to prove this
in humans to test the results in humans
they acquired frozen ovary tissue from a
colleague in Japan who treats women
seeking gender reassignment but they
needed a way to fish out the stem cells
from the adult eggs surrounding them in
the ovary a major breakthrough that's
reported in the nature medicine paper is
the ability to isolate these cells and
purify them and the strategy that we
used is really in a way similar to a
tether being exposed on the outside of
these cells and that tether is a piece
of a protein a gene product that's
expressed only by these cells in the
outer layer of the ovary are stem cells
that the team's suspected could create
viable eggs to purify the stem cells
they used what they knew about a protein
called DD x4 in mature eggs DD x4 is
inside the cell but in stem cells that
sticks out like a rope when antibodies
against
d/dx four are added they can come in and
grab on to that rope separating the stem
cells from the egg cells a labeling
protein tags the cells to make them glow
green the Green makes the stem cells
traceable tillery's lab injected some of
them into human ovary tissue and
transplanted this into a live mouse
there the green cells matured into new
human eggs and we knew that day and the
hairs are standing up on my arm that
indeed these cells existed in humans I
think probably among every other
observation we've made that has to be
the most important when the stem cells
are placed into a dish containing normal
ovary tissue we can watch them mature
creating the first video footage of
human eggs being born for women's
reproductive health these findings have
so many ramifications again if you think
that for years our clinicians practiced
under the assumption that that egg cell
pool was finite everything that was
designed clinically was to wrap designed
around the idea that that egg cell pool
was all they had to work with one of the
main findings of the paper in Nature
Medicine is that these cells when
maintained outside the body are more
than happy to make eggs on their own and
if we can guide that process correctly I
think it opens up the chance that
sometime in the future we might get to
the point of actually having an
unlimited source of human eggs that a
woman could come in have a small biopsy
taken from her ovary for us to retrieve
these cells and once we get these cells
out we can take a hundred of them and
make a million of them if we could get
to the stage of generating functional
human eggs outside the body it would
rewrite essentially human assisted
reproduction
you
you